almost twenty years have passed since
9/11 it is time to take stock of where
we stand and stop and think it is time
to ask ourselves if the assumptions and
policies we develop in the wake of those
tragic events truly made us more secure
have they made our societies both in
Europe and they near in the United
States more resilient I've worked all my
life in the field of security and
defense and I am convinced then now more
than ever we need to radically reframe
the way we think and act about security
and especially about international
security the international security I
actually mean what we do how we prepare
our countries to better respond and
prevent external threats and how we
protect our citizens the key to both is
to focus on protecting civilians both in
our own countries and in those where we
are present in the name of security now
this idea goes against the fixed
narrative that we developed over the
past 20 years over what security is and
how to get it but that narrative is
flawed and worse it is counterproductive
over the past 20 years both in the
United States and new in Europe we've
come to accept that we must talk about
security in zero-sum terms as if the
only way to gain more security is by
compromising on values and rights
security vs. human rights safety versus
freedom and development this is a false
opposition it just doesn't work like
that we need to recognize the security
and human rights are not opposite values
they are intrinsically related after all
the most basic human right is the right
to live and to be free from violence and
a state's most basic responsibility will
is to guarantee that right for its
cities
conversely if we think about communities
all over the world affected by war and
conflict
it is insecurity and violence that stops
them from achieving their full freedom
and development now they need basic
security just as much as we do and they
need it so they can live a normal life
and so that they can enjoy their human
rights this is why we need a shift we
need to acknowledge the sustainable
security builds on a foundation of human
rights builds on promoting and
respecting human rights also over the
past two decades we have accepted that
the best way to guarantee our own
security is by defeating our enemies and
to do that we need to rely almost
exclusively on the military again
disclosure with my work with my research
what I see in the field what I see is
that building sustainable security has a
lot less to do with crushing enemies has
a lot less to do with winning on the
battlefield and has a lot more to do
with protecting victims and building
stability and to do that while the
military alone is simply insufficient
this is why I believe we need to shell
the never ending war on terror and we
need to replace it with a security
agenda that is driven by the principle
of protecting civilians no matter where
they're from what password a old or
where they live Vancouver New York Kabul
Mosul Aleppo or Duma sustainable
security tells us that we're more likely
to have long term security at home for
ourselves if we focus our engagements
abroad on protecting civilians and on
ensuring their lives are lived in
dignity and free from violence for
example we all know that defeating Isis
is the security achievement absolutely
but rebuilding destroyed homes restore
in order ensuring a representative
political system these are just as if
not more important
and not just for the security of
civilians in Iraq and in Syria but for
our own security and for global
stability more fundamentally Isis danger
should not just be counted in the number
of weapons it holds but also in the
number of children it has kept out of
school or indoctrinated this is from a
security perspective from a security
perspective the long term generational
impact will have been millions of
children in Syria growing up knowing
only war and out of school this is a far
more dangerous threat to stability than
all of Isis weapons combined and we
should spend just as much time and just
as much energy to counter this as what
we spent when countering Isis time
militarily over the past two decades our
security policy has been short term it
has focused on the here and now it has
systematically downplayed the link
between what we do today in the name of
security and the long term impact of
those choices in the years after 9/11
some of the choices some of the policies
we've implemented have probably made us
less not more secure in the long term
sustainable civilian center security
needs to look at what happens in the
long term again for example relying on
drones to target enemies in faraway
countries may be a tool it may be a tool
to make sure or to lessen the threat of
an imminent attack on the United States
but what about the long-term impact if
civilians are killed
if communities are targeted this will
feed a vicious circle of war conflict
trauma and radicalization and that
vicious circle is at the center of so
many of the security challenges we face
today this will not make us safer in the
long term we need civilian security we
need sustainable civilian
centered security and we need it now we
need to encourage thinking and research
around this concept and to implement it
we live in a dangerous world we have
many threats to peace and conflicts much
like in the days after 9/11 we simply
cannot afford not to think about
international security well we have to
learn the lessons of the past 20 years
to get it right to get security right we
need to focus on the long term we need
to focus on protecting civilians and we
need to respect and acknowledge the fact
the sustainable security builds on a
foundation of human rights otherwise in
the name of security we risk living the
world a far more dangerous and an
unstable place than what we already
found it thank you
[Applause]